ça commençait des nations je reçois des
décotes sur foi de génériques à rien
comme ça mais on met la clé sous la
porte savalou qui très bientôt
alors tu t'appelles lucchi way look yves
hilton c'est ça mes frères
tu es un nom de cette au nom de celle où
c'est je l'appelle vraiment lucchi ville
donne mais j'adore here est de danser
avec telly sa chroniqueuse préféré et
bakkali et là tu es là tu lances
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
apprendra les jeux c'est dans moins
d'une heure enfin dans une heure
maintenant ça sera la de la france
entière attend j'aimerais dire le monde
c'était un peu abusé le lancement de à
prendre ou à laisser
un poil voilà on direct animée par vous
excusez moi c'est déjà décroché je suis
sur arte mais je regarde la route idéale
une petite blagounette sur sur le sens
inverse voiture à la belge qui est sur
l'autoroute alors j'adore les belges à
moi aussi je les adore jouer et les sur
l'autoroute il entend la radio attention
attention automobilistes la lâche pas
quoi il ya un automobiliste qui roule le
trou ton sens inverse belge louis la pac
à nyala 2 3 4 5 6 soit pas pour quelle
raison on ouvrirait pas les collèges le
collège compte y avait pas de n'y a pas
d'apéro russie d'impérieux rue cité pas
d'urgence à le renvoyer
à 70 % non à 34% et vous voyez que les
téléspectateurs sont plutôt
conservateurs m
voilà un niveau aa temps d'écrire elle
ajouté oui oui c'est la pince oui oui la
pince qu'est ce que tu veux
oui la pince
ouais j'ai envie
[Musique]
c'était banques et je dois y aller tu
l'apprends doit laisser ses parts c'est
que du kif salue les chercher pire une
nouvelle recrue dans l'équipe c'est jean
pascal
la caa rascal bien sûr que j'aime
beaucoup khalifa sall regarde et qu'on
va voir page toujours pascal leader est
ce qu'on peut faire un plan sur yon
basque à l'esc est toujours un
réalisateur jean pascal
je vais te poser des questions à chaque
fois que tu répondras mal j'enlèverai
donc un petit bâtonnet d'en haut
ce sont des ballons avec de l'eau que
traîne jean-michel mer au pied depuis
près de dix ans même ceux qui veulent
manger je prends pour attraper les
grands âges enlève un truc qui ceint par
tous et bien sûr jean michel mr traîne
un logement on arrête là c'est bon tu te
passer à une nouvelle reprise
ça s'appelle le top 14 du post on va
revenir sur les 14 meilleures images du
jour est venue de la séquence on était
obligé d'avoir avec nous un spécialiste
de la télé et du rugby
je vous demande d'accueillir bernard
laporte
je l'équipe de france pour lancer une
séquence et t'as vu comment tu prends m
mais regardez non regardez comment il
prend le ballon bernard laporte
on voit que c'est pas comme vous
regardez regardez cette classe regagner
le caresse non messieurs rien ni le
charisme regarde regarde tu fais du bien
et je voudrais dire tu seras avec moi
l'année prochaine dans balances ton post
est menée sur ces voix là aussi je
voulais vous faire cette annonce bien
sûr il sera avec moi dans balances ton
poste l'année prochaine bernard laporte
aurait roland garros ouais ouais
eh bien je vais vous dire on va faire un
petit jeu on va chronométrés vous pouvez
faire service que voilà coup droit
cuillère tout ce que vous voulez car il
ya une machine pour chronométrer celui
qui fera la balle la plus rapide et la
balle chronométrés la plus puissante
désignera celui qui sera déguisé en
andre agassi toutes les missions andre
agassi de l'époque voyez avec la période
comme ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
on voudrait nous y voilà
bon allez on a un jeune homme d'un seul
qui fait le public aujourd'hui regardez
comme ils apprécient les beaufs une très
bonne idée manie type solution mais
qu'est ce que c'est que ce beau gosse
comment il s'appelle
je m'appelle théo il a une bonne prise
déjà un énorme et loup c'est un grand
joueur regardés comme des grands il est
grand il est longue regardez moi là a du
coup ça fait six mois
alexandria on a professionnels scène je
sers trop fort mais non mais c'est ça on
peut bien pressés devant moi et mes
adjoints aussi un accord et là il sert
près pendant les années un hall à la
casse brassens c'est lucas bravo à vous
proposons une deuxième deuxième phase du
monsieur en plus il est élégant mais il
est très élégant mais révèle tout est ok
je suis pas bien enfin les billets par
2,2 aussi sandrine allée g choisir tu
peux me soit 0,6 du bruit non je pense
que je choisirais mme leuthard
c'est l'image du jour et vous allez voir
raymond en d'aidé à gaza
alors andré néron andré verreault
d'assassiner mayrand pardo qu'est-ce
qu'elle a dénoncés pas du tout andre
agassi journée de tennis à l'arrière
dénoncé du temps là vous devrez juste
banderas aussi c'est un peu aussi
j'ai gagné là bas elle est belle elle
est belle la france ont fait ping pong
et les boîtes ce soir allez moi
déstabiliser mais c'est la guerre
psychologique 3 2 heures il faut se
reconcentrer la france à l'aquarium
c'est pas tes petits copains de boîte de
nuit
la qualité de la balle du mois juste une
petite question
oui ça fait combien d'années que ça doit
marquer pour monsieur je crois qu'avec 2
0 a donné de belles serpillière aller
[Rires]
dit et tu veux que je te dise mon chéri
ou bien il sera chroniqueur d'un jour
dans ces cris du public parce que ça te
fait plaisir moss eric mais c'est sûr et
bien sûr le ménage chez moi tu me fais
rire qu'isabelle vous allez pouvoir vous
venez ça m'étonnerait pourquoi isabelle
sous quelles conditions les boîtes de
nuit à berlin qui peuvent réouvrir je
prépare quand même larmes
ouais parce que là ils pensent que la
tradition des bals et s'est terminée à
dix lors attendez attendez attendez la
foule attendait oh oh oh c'est bien cela
[Musique]
ça suffit au repos regardez pourquoi